across the country there are sad stories
of thousands of delinquents who are
skipping school of course I'm talking
about teachers a persistent funding
shortage which has caused public schools
6.6 billion dollars since 2009 led them
to walk off the job and close down
schools last week I have a problem with
them just going on strike they should
all be fired I'm here at the Capitol in
Denver where thousands of teachers have
walked out of school to ask for more pay
we have waited long enough we have
worked hard enough we have been quiet
long enough that something has to happen
now okay I'm sorry I feel like you're
using an outside voice right now
maybe you should use your inside voices
when you're striking I'm a teacher I
don't have an inside voice
Colorado's got one of the worst funded
k12 systems in the country even though
it's got one of the most booming
economies in the country why do you
think teachers across the country are
striking now honestly I'm just inspired
by the student activism I've seen around
the country so if a teenager asks for
higher pay for teachers and jumped off a
bridge would you - when they stand up on
principle I think it's our job to stand
there with him it's so sad to see him
peer pressured by these kids to follow
the program smoking cigarettes in an
alley and demanding a living wage
they're all wearing red for the blood no
it's red for public ed nationwide
politicians have been trying their best
to keep these teachers in school through
inaction blaming them for abuse and even
threatening to put them in jail but the
teachers keep striking
luckily I've seen some movies and I know
exactly what to do when kids or 40 year
olds are acting out all these hooligans
need to turn their life around is a cool
white Savior in a big leather jacket who
sits backwards on her chair and inspires
them with poetry so I started my way
into this grim Denver suburb to meet up
with the teachers who walked out of
school and Dangerous Minds the out of
them
[Music]
things are gonna be different around
here wait here was an apple I believe
that you have potential but then I see
you walking out of school you know I was
gonna say have to walk out for one day
sometimes you have to ruffle feathers to
make a bigger impact we decided we need
to take action we need to make sure our
legislators listen and they start being
held accountable we're getting
shortchanged our students are getting
shortchanged and we want change got a
little poetry for you guys because if I
know one thing it's that a white lady
who's into poetry can save some juvenile
delinquents okay so whoever wants to
just start by reading one of the lines
off their poetry please application for
McDonald's employment yes what else
Home Depot music to my ears an
application for a second job that a lot
of teachers hold yes yes yes why have
one job when you can have two or three
why should teachers just do one job when
you're so capable sometimes it's a
struggle I teach over the summer and I
do some odd jobs here and there to make
ends meet
so that I can have a reasonable standard
of living I want to put my time and
energy into my students into my
classroom I can't do a second job and be
the best teacher I could be they weren't
moved by my poetry I had to go full-on
uplifting Montag repeat after me
better contract and more resources
aren't out there these are excuses I can
live on thirty thousand dollars a year
you can I can't I make at least two
hundred thousand dollars a year and I
deduct all of my facials and haircuts my
plan isn't working at this movies almost
over we need a plot twist so I tried
listening to that ok wise guys you know
better than me how would you solve this
problem smaller class sizes I would make
sure our schools were fully funded and
make sure our kids mental health needs
are met I'd look to start equitably tax
our wealthy and our corporations they
get the biggest tax breaks and we are
shortchanged because of it
okay but the thing is that doesn't make
for a good story it's like the funner
story is you guys overcome it on your
own and I think you get pregnant and
maybe you get shot that's a good story
problem is we're not a story our
students lives these are future some
people can't be saved in fact this week
at least 10,000 Colorado teachers
returned to the streets for a strike
following in the footsteps of these
other states some predict North Carolina
is next me and my big leather jacket
smell is sequel
[Music]